[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Закарпаття,
гора Гемба, Чайовня Сурія]
Прийшов якийсь час і я запитала себе:
«А що ти хочеш робити?
Що ти можеш робити?»
І сама собі відповіла,
що я можу створити атмосферу.
Так з'явився цей проєкт — чайовня Сурія,
[Юлія Омельченко
Засновниця Чайовні Сурія]
який спочатку був кочовим, пересувним.
Він кочував по фестивалях.
Я сюди приїхала просто відпочити.
Я не думала тут робити чайовню.
Я не думала робити тут якийсь проєкт.
Я просто піднялась на гору і подумала,
що тут дуже класно,
[дитина чхає]
і там хочу провести якийсь час.
Я тут лишилась.
Ніхто до цього не мав жодного досвіду
будівництва, тим більше на висоті.
І це було надзвичайно цікаво,
починаючи від взаємодії з місцевим населенням,
з пошуком робітників для будівництва.
Це було дуже важко,
тому що це був...
Це був грудень!
Було дуже холодно.
І ми 31-го (не січня, а грудня)
завезли нагору все обладнання.
І я так туди зайшла в це приміщення
і думаю: «Боже! Що далі робити?»
Ну от — що робити?
Просто ти в приміщенні,
в якому піч не топилась ні разу.
Весь цей процес не відпрацьований.
Купа якихось ящиків
із якимось обладнанням, посудом.
І ми повільно-повільно почали
це все розкладати по полицях, розставляти.
Й вже до 12-ї години у нас
вималювався якийсь такий казковий простір,
що я просто... я здивована була сама.
Я відчувала його до цього.
Тобто він у мене був тут завжди.
Я його відчувала, коли його створювала.
Але коли він уже проявився,
це було щось фантастичне.
І зранку в двері чайовні
просто як морська хвиля
вломилась купа туристів,
які почали [говорити]: «Давайте щось нам!»
І, до речі, перший пісок,
який ми привезли на каву,
він був з Грузії — магнітний пісок.
Чорний, дуже красивий — з Поті.
А зараз, до речі, там змішались два піски:
один з Грузії, а інший з Гангу.
Спочатку ми перебували там тиждень,
не спускаючись,
намагаючись якось зрозуміти цей процес.
Потім стало легше: туристи поїхали вже.
В такій кількості їх не було.
І ми уже в такому
спокійному повільному ритмі
почали якось по-трошечки приходити до тями.
Уже з'явилось деяке розуміння
за ці три роки.
У нас було багато людей,
також багато,
які працюють, можна сказати,
постійно.
Це фантастично.
Я не знаю, як можна мотивувати,
наприклад, людину,
у якої раптово щось закінчилось,
або екстренна ситуація
і вона розуміє, що це необхідно для гори.
І просто після 10-годинного робочого дня
вона просто спускається вниз
і просто пішки потім піднімається нагору.
Була в Санкт-Петербурзі,
і я там спробувала вперше в житті збитень.
І була просто вражена.
Мені настільки сподобалась
ця комбінація смаків —
власне кислоти, пряності і меду.
І коли я повернулась в Україну,
почала цікавитись,
почала читати про цей рецептурний напій,
і просто вирішила його відновити.
Це було зі збитню.
Я пам'ятаю, що коли ми приїхали,
вони готували «Ліптон».
Вони готували «Ліптон»
і продавали якісь чипси, шоколадки.
І вони намагалися
про нас інтриги наводити,
розповідати туристам страшні речі,
але з нас це сходило, не чіплялось,
тому що, насправді, не було за що.
Ми навіть ніколи на них не злились.
Зараз я мрію
зробити цей процес бездоганним.
Ну ось так...
Починаючи від...
Ну ось на всіх етапах.
Тобто це і збір [чаю],
і переробка, і пакування,
і далі його розповсюдження.
Ну от зараз, власне,
я відпрацьовую якийсь варіант
ферментації, пресування, сушки.
Пробую, дивлюсь, що може бути кращим.
І також працюю над брендом.
Я би хотіла зробити tea-factory,
якусь би чайну фабрику,
як-от є, наприклад, на Шрі-Ланці.
З прекрасними шоу-румами,
де людина могла б
долучитися до процесу —
також переминати чай.
Де вона бачила б цей процес.
Не бутафорно, а де дійсно
сиділи б люди,
які би все це там робили.
Була ідея автоматизувати цей процес,
принаймні, наприклад, перетирання трави,
але потім я зрозуміла,
що це абсолютно дві різні категорії.
І зараз дівчата його перетирають вручну.
Мені не дуже цікаво бути в місті.
А зараз уже, як на мене,
пройшов час того бізнесу,
коли треба ставати на роздоріжжі
при дорозі, на перехресті доріг,
в якихось людних місцях,
і все таке інше.
Зараз, з усіма цими комунікаціями,
і взагалі все настільки змінилось,
що неважливо де ти є,
якщо ти дійсно щось робиш правильне,
достойне, то тобі
не треба його продавати.
Не треба думати взагалі про бізнес.
Ти просто живеш.
Живеш у процесі.
Робиш те, що можеш,
від чого кайфуєш.
Моя найвища ідея —
це бачити цей світ красивим.
Саме бачити,
тому що це все йде через мене.
І я рада бачити цей світ красивим.
Це моя основна ідея.
Коли я приходжу в чайовню,
і коли бачу якийсь такий момент,
коли залітає, наприклад,
купа туристів,
а вони купили пакет: за день їм
треба відвідати ще 10 якихось локацій,
з ними гід/екскурсовод,
який постійно нагадує про таймінг,
а потім на якусь секунду
людина бере келих з чаєм
або навіть не бере ніякого чаю,
просто до вікна підходить —
і замовкає...
До того ж тотально замовкає.
Я просто бачу, що в цей момент
відбулась ця зустріч.
Все... Я розумію, що все...
Мене це дуже надихає.
Я розумію, що ось є ціль цього всього.
[Оператор
Дмитро Охріменко]
[Монтаж
Дмитро Кошевий]
[Музика
Endless Melancholy]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]